Hello
uh Mr. Jakir this is Aurora Vive being a
Hindu over here I'm not over here to put
any controversy but I have a question
aam brahma aam Vishnu aamah that was
called by someone of my very good friend
eventually he was telling us about Quran
and Bible but what my question is I have
got just four question to ask to you
number one
most important question first I
if there is time we will definitely
permit you another question.
No issues. No issues
because if everyone asks two three
questions if I as an coordinator allow I
think we are not being fair to the other
questioners.
Fine thank I got your point. Just one
question as though Mr. Jak you were
talking about Genesis version and
everything. I just have a put wonder
question. If you are making a comparison
between the Quran and Bible, why not a
comparison between the Vedas, the Quran
and the Bible? They are versileile in
each every manner. One eventually is
cooperated with each other. God the
Almighty is one. Rather it called be as
a Allah, it's called by Bhagwan or
Jesus. Why not make it sure all of the
people should say why not only one
brother asked a very good question very
important question very practical
question when I'm making comparison
between Quran and the Bible why not make
comparison between Quran Bible Veda etc
and he said that why don't you follow
all and that is what I tell the people
that's what the Quran says
come to common terms asked me to assign
you brother. What I tell every human
being any whether it be a Hindu,
Christian, Muslim, Jew, Sikh, Pari, no
problem. I tell them a simple thing
which everyone will agree at least agree
that one scripture is the word of God.
No one would mind doing that. The Hindu
would say okay fine V is the word of
God. Christian will say Bible is the
word of God. Muslim will say Quran is
the word of God. The sick he'll say
mrant is the word of God. The pari he
will say that my a word of god no
problem. Now put all these scriptures
together. What is common let us agree to
follow that. What is not common we can
discuss that tomorrow. Friend I only ask
them one thing. What is common in all
the scriptures let us agree to follow
because
sorry to interrupt you sir. Sorry to
interrupt you
brother. Please let me complete the
answer and after
please please please
after I finish after I finish the answer
what you want you can say. Maybe what
you want to ask I will give in the
answer correct I going stepwise
right sir
the mathematical if you want to solve a
problem if I direct give you the answer
you won't understand I have to go step
wise 1 2 3 4 5
exactly
so my only request is what is common in
all the scripture let us follow what is
not common we'll discuss later on
fine now common in all the scripture is
that god is one so let Believe God is
one. We say that God is one. Didn't I
say that?
God is only one without a second. Bible
says that. Gospel of Mark chapter number
12 verse number 29. Book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 6 verse number four. Shel
your Israel the Lord our God is one. The
Jews say that. The Christians say that.
Quran says
say there's God one and only. So where
does this trinity come in between? Where
does this Brahma, Vishnu and Shiva come
in between? Where?
I didn't believe in that
brother, let me complete. There is no
Brahma mentioned in the Quran. There is
no Shiva mentioned in the Quran.
There is no Jesus mentioned in the Quran
that he's God. It's mentioned in the
Quran. He's a messenger of God. The
Bible also doesn't say that Jesus is
God. It is the false reading of the
Christians. So how come you are saying
that it doesn't matter whether Allah
Jesus it matters?
The Quran says
in surah is chapter number 17 verse
number 11
say call upon him by Allah or by raman
but whichever name you call upon him to
him belongs the most beautiful names it
should be a beautiful name it should not
conjure up a mental picture it should be
a true name you can't give a false name
to god you can't insult God you can't
belittle god some people tell me what
different does it make you call pani you
You call water, you call tani, no
problem. If you call pani, you say in
Hindi. Tani, you say in Tamil. Moya or
my you say in Arabic.
Jal, you say in Hindi. No problem. You
can call by any name. But then one
morning my friend comes and tells me
every morning I have water.
But after I have water, the doctor told
me I have a lot of water but I start
vomiting. I said why? No, the water is
yellowish. The doctor told him to have
water. He has every morning one glass of
water. The water is yellowish.
Yellowish.
Yellowish. Then I realize what he's
talking is not water. It is urine.
You can't call urine as water. The
definition of water. You can call tani.
You can call water. You can say Raman.
You can say Raheim. You can say Karim.
You can say Rab. But you can't call God
as man. You can't call God as Insan.
Therefore, you can't call water as
urine. And the touchstone for theology
is suras. Chapter number 112 verse
number 1 to4. What I mentioned suras. So
what I'm going to tell that what is
different? Keep it aside. Nowhere does
the Quran says that Jesus is God.
Nowhere does the Quran says Mah is God.
So keep Mahes out. Yes. If you say
Brahma,
Brahma is a Sanskrit word which is known
as a creator God. So if you say creator,
I've got no problem. If you say God is a
creator, I've got no problem. Because
Quran says that God is kalik creator.
But then you say this creator has got
four heads. He has got four hands. Then
you're giving an image to God. You're
going against Veda.
Of that God there is no image.
I do believe. You
call him creator. But you say that
creator is a man then he's not God.
I do have an apology the creator. So
same way brother if you see my video
cassette similarities between Islam and
Hinduism inshallah most of your carries
will be answered. Hope that answers the
question. I
I do apologize what I was specifically
want to say to you Mr. Jakir I do not
want to get into controversy over here.
My thing is this Mr. Jakir was telling
appropriately right what exactly was
over here the people is wanting what I
wanted to know basically
exactly what he the speeches he's
providing to us we are over to listen
him
exactly the renaissa the renaissa the
creator of the world rather it should be
counted as Allah
bhaguan one or the Jesus should not be
created in self. It has to be
materialized with differentiations.
Thank you
brother. If you had heard my answer you
call him Allah. I've got no problem.
You call him Bhagwan as long as what is
the meaning of Bhagwan? According to
Rajnish Bhagwan means something else. I
don't know whether you know according to
Rajnish.
What definition Rajnish gave then I
cannot believe God is Bhagavan. So what
we have to realize we have to believe in
the concept
of the almighty the creator the maker.
If you know that concept and the word
should be chosen correct. It should not
be a wrong word. And what word is common
between the scriptures? We have got no
objection. But Jesus as you again
mentioned is not common in the Bible and
the Quran. Quran says Jesus is a prophet
of God and even the Bible says the
prophet of God but the Christian they
misunderstand that Jesus claimed
divinity. So if the Christians they
misunderstand the Bible why should I
agree with the misunderstanding I have
to clarify that I have not come here to
create a controversy I've come here to
come to common terms
come to common terms asen you
yes can we have the next question from
the sister
I'm Dr. Dr. Puja Aurora. I'm from S
Hospital. I'm a physotherapist. Uh so I
totally agree with you. Just a small
question. When uh Muhammad prophet
attained his propheththood
uh and as you said he was a common man
before he attained prophethood by that
time. Is it that Quran which is the word
of God has enlightened only Muslims
because God can't be partial? So what
was the rest of the world doing when
Muhammad prophet was enlightening a
small sect of people and is it that such
a long time is being taken for the rest
of the sector of society to just get
enlightened to this word of God and how
many years would the non-H Muslims like
Hindus would I totally agree with you it
has to be a concept Hindus are believing
idols pictures but or Ram Bhagan
whatever but it is a concept and they
have to be enlightened about it that it
is one. Hinduism also follows uh an
almighty which is a power a divine power
but unfortunately it has been given in
various forms. So this enlightenment if
Quran helps a Hindu to know this
enlightenment it is fabulous.
Sister asked a very good question and a
very important question.
She said that if Quran is such a great
book, if it's a word of almighty god,
then why when it came to prophet
Muhammad, it was only meant for that
small group, you know, Arabs of that
time, only Muslim. Why not for the full
world? How long will it take? Sister,
the Quran was never revealed only for
the Muslims or for the Arabs. The Quran
was revealed for the whole of humanity.
It's mentioned in surah Ibrahim chapter
number 14 verse number one. in surah
Ibrahim chapter number 14 verse number
52 in surah bakar chapter number two
verse number 185 and surah zumar chapter
number 39 verse number 41 that the Quran
was sent for the whole of humanity time
is short therefore I'm only giving
references not the quotations so Quran
was not sent only for the Muslim and the
Arabs the Quran was sent for the whole
of humanity and prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he was not sent only for the
Muslims Arabs the Quran says in surah
amyia chapter number 21 verse number 107
that we have sent thee not but as as a
mercy to all the human beings, as a
mercy to all the worlds, as a mercy to
all the creatures. The message is
repeated in surah Sabah chapter number
34 verse number 28 that prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him is sent as a universal
messenger giving glad tidings and
warning them against sins but most of
the human beings yet do not know. Now
this verse of the Quran says most of the
human beings yet do not know. That's the
reason sister we are having such
conferences. It's the duty of every
Muslim that you should convey the word
of almighty God to all the human beings.
So one more thing sir can I ask?
It may take time but better late than
never sister. Better late than never.
And everyone who claims to be a Muslim
may not be a practicing Muslim. He may
have a name Abdullah Zakir Muhammad
Sultan but he may not be a practicing
Muslim.
Similarly as you rightly said in
Hinduism you don't follow your
scriptures but yet the religion which is
the maximum followed not only by lip
service but in practice today it is
Islam number one
in numbers Christianity
it is close to 2 billion Muslims
claiming is 1.3 billion but the people
practicing the religion number one is
Islam
percentage wise it is the
So these lectures are mainly those small
percentage of Muslims who are not
following Islam correctly to get them
closer to Islam and to those non-Muslims
we want to give the message of peace,
the message of love
and prove to the world that there is
only one God. The ultimate peace can
only come if you submit a will to
almighty God. That is the only way to
get ultimate peace in this world and
thereafter. So that is the reason sister
we are having such conferences. We have
a satellite channel peace TV where every
day more than 60 million people they're
watching it. So at least on the day of
judgment we can give shada to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. Y we did our best
whatever we could we at least gave the
message every day at least to 60 million
people. And today the message has even
reached you sister. So tomorrow on the
day of judgment I can tell to almighty
God I gave the message to the sister
whether you accept or not is in your
hand sister
[applause]
I just want to add can I thank you very
much sir uh just one more thing if
because God is impartial so on the day
of judgment as you did a partiality that
non-Muslims should be given first
priority to ask their questions God is
impartial so If Hindus stop believing in
idols and pictures and they start
believing in the Almighty which has got
no form, no shape and on the day of
judgment is it that they will be not
behaved as Muslims by God? No, it is not
like that. It is the concept which is
there in Hinduism the misbelief that is
followed in forms. But if and Hindu
following Hindu religion is not wrong
but following because your aim is God he
is the supreme he should not have form
but if this message is reached to
Hinduism you have won it
very good sister very good question
thank you sir
regarding we being partial partial there
can be two different views from your
side because we're partial at least you
could ask a question [laughter]
if I wasn't partial I couldn't tell to
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala I gave you the
message directly one everyone you know
so
he doesn't he doesn't believe
so what you have to realize sister but
why we are partial we are partial to be
impartial because the others have got
the message if not 100% 90%. You all
have got less. So we are partial to be
impartial.
Right sir? So what we need
coming back to your question sister? Yes
sir.
It's a very good question that if the
Hindus believe in one God, do not
believe in idol, do not believe in
images, do not believe in statues on the
day of judgment, won't we be Muslims?
Correct. You are following part of
Islam. Correct. If you read the Hindu
scriptures further, the Hindu scriptures
say there is another messenger to come.
And the coming of Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him has been prophesized in
various places. He's prophesized in
Bhavisha Purana, Parvatri, Kanda 3, Adya
3, shlokas 5 to 8. He's prophesized in
Bhavisha Purana, Parvatri,
Adya 3, shlokas 10 to 27. He's
prophesized in the ve
chapter number 21 verse number 6.
Atarvid chapter number 21 verse number 7
he's prophesized in several places he is
mentioned by name no less than 100 times
as Muhammad in the Hindu scriptures time
doesn't permit me to mention all the
references there is mention of a khali
aar in khalki purana chapter number two
verse number four 5 7 9 11 and 15 it
says that there is another utar to come
kiar whose father's name shall be the
servant of god Vishnu yash translated
into Arabic as abdu which was the name
of the father of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. The mother's name of
this kytar
would be Sumati that means peace and
serenity which is amina in Arabic which
was the name of prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam mother. This person will
be born on the 12th day of Madav the
12th that is the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam born he'll have four
companions and we know the first paras
it says that he will be born in a place
which is peaceful in Makkah he'll be
born in a house of the chief of Makkah
that is the Qur tribe it says that he
will go northwards from a cave and come
back and prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam went from Makkah to
Madina and came back on and on talking
about so you believe in one partillah
you also have to believe in mother
Allah.
Thank you sir. Thank [applause] you.
And if you do this you keep your name
whatever your name was whether Priy
whatever name sister what is the name
sister?
Puja.
Puja. You keep your name don't change
your name but indeed you will be a
Muslim. Changing your name is not
required.
So the concept
concept of one god no statue no images
last final messenger prophet Muhammad
inshallah on the day of judgment you
will go to heaven with your name puja.
So the pathways are different. The only
thing is the goal should be the same.
That is what I believe
for the goal pathways are different. If
both the different pathways go TO THE
SAME GOAL,
LOOK AT the same goal. Yes sir. That is
what I want to say.
All the roads don't lead to Rome. Sister
fine. You may think it will lead. So if
you think falsely I have to correct you.
I don't believe. No sir.
No sister. If you say you're a Hindu by
definition,
Hindu is a person who lives in India.
No sir, it's not like that
sister. Hindu is a geographical
definition. You don't know. I know. I am
a Hindu by geographical definition. I'm
a Hindu. Geographically,
sister. The word Hindu was first used by
the Arabs. There are many Arabs here.
They call me Hindi when I go there.
Hindi. Hindi.
They tell I'm Hindu. The word Hindu was
first used by the Arabs when they came
to India. It was also used by the
Persians to describe the people who
lived in India. So geographically I'm a
Hindu. But if you tell me religiously
Hindu is a misnomer. Swami Viveandha
said the right term is a Vantist. You
should follow the Vedas. So as far as
you follow the right things in the Veda,
believe in one God and believing in
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam by deed you are a Muslim.
So the religion can't be powerful. The
ultimate power is Allah.
Correct. I agree with you.
Power is God
and the religion of God and the religion
of God is ultimate religion.
So the religion of God is not Islam. The
religion of God is not Islam.
Islam. If Islam is Arabic word which is
hurting you, you keep Islam aside.
No. No. I is not hurting me. I'm telling
you sister.
Not hurting me.
If it's not hurting you, nobody.
No sir. It is a park word in itself. How
it can hurt anybody? At least not a
educated girl.
Mashallah. You're educated girl sister.
Yes.
Thank you so much. Thank you sir.
Sister Islam means submitting a will to
God. So if Islam is a problem keep Islam
aside but submit your will to God. Allah
says in the Quran in surah Al Iran 3
verse number 19lam
the only religion the only way of life
accepted in the sight of Allah is
submitting our will to almighty God.
Yes brother.
Uh Mr. Nay uh this is myself Dr. from
Suryakan Pawar from Central Hospital. Uh
thanks for the nice and enlightening
lecture about the Quran as God's word.
As you mentioned that Quran is God's
word, I just want to ask you who is the
creator of the God? What is the origin
of God?
Brother asked a very good question that
if Quran is the word of God, who is the
creator of God? Very good question.
If I ask you brother that your friend
John he gave birth to a child. Can you
guess the child was girl or a boy? Your
friend John gave birth to a child in the
hospital. Can you guess was it a girl or
a boy?
Guess. Guess.
No.
Girl or a boy?
I can't guess.
Sorry.
I may not guess.
Try. At least 50% will get right.
Yeah. 50% one half chance.
Okay. Tell me.
Boy.
Whether can a man give birth to a child?
No.
So is it a girl or a boy?
But the name can be called a female.
I'm asking you your friend John.
I don't know anyone female called by
John.
No, we can call now.
Okay. Suppose a friend who's a boy. He's
a man. He went to hospital. He gave
birth to a child. Was it a girl or a
boy?
Girl.
Can a man give birth to a child,
brother?
No. [laughter] Ah now you understood a
man can't give birth to a child. So
where's the question of it being girl or
a boy? So by definition god is
uncreated.
So the question who is the creator of
god is like I asking you a question your
friend who's a man he gave birth to a
child is it a girl or a boy? The
question is illogical because by
definition a man cannot give birth to a
child. So where's the question of girl
or a boy? So by definition god is
uncreated.
every created thing has a creator. God
does not have a creator. Therefore, in
my argument with the atheist and never
ever said that everything has a creator.
I said every created thing has a
creator. But the god is uncreated. By
definition, the moment I mention who is
the creator of god, he's not god.
Therefore, by definition, god is
uncreated. Hope that answers the
question. Okay. Thank you.
The next question from the brother in
the back.
My name is Peter. I'm a student of
religion philosophy.
Now my question is on the textual
authenticity of the Quran. First when
Abu Bakr commanded Z to gather the text
together, he did that.
But there is also written in al-Bkari
volume number five page 96. Abdul Masoud
he was the
uh authority mentioned by Muhammad he
gathered a text.
Then Salim the freed slave he gathered a
text. and also uh Ubab
a master reciter mentioned by Muhammad.
And there are also other people who
compiled their test. But when Usman
became the Khalifa,
he ordered Zad to make replicas, seven
replicas
of his text and sent it to the different
parts
and ordered those previous text to be
burned.
Now
if those master reciters compiled the
Quran and Usman ordered those texts to
be burned.
Now there raises a question on the
authenticity of the Quran.
Mashallah brother knows about Masud may
Allah peace with him about may Allah be
pleas with him. Mashallah many of the
Muslim will not know those names.
You know now it's easy to go on the
internet.
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said in
the gospel of John chapter number 8
verse number 32 seek the truth and the
truth shall free you. Now when internet
is there many people go on the internet
there are various websites which are
speaking against Islam. They go they get
the name and they decide no problem
brother
no problem brother. As far the question
is concerned, the people who compiled
the Quran, there was a group of Sahabah
as the companion of the prophet.
Whenever prophet got a revelation, he
repeated it to these scribes and suppose
he got the revelation and prophet
mashallah very good memory. Allah saw to
it that he memory he repeated it. When
he repeated the scribe wrote down the
prophet personally verified he was a ni.
How did he verify? Okay, read it now.
Ah, correct. So prophet personally
verified when he was alive whatever was
written down of the Quran whether it was
perfect or not under his personal
supervision and these scribes they were
selected by the prophet and that's how
when the revelation came in 22 and a
half years all was written down and
later compiled in one book all
supervised by prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam even the order now later on
there were many other people whenever
the prophet said a verse was revealed
field they used to write in his own
notes
many many sabas but this private notes
of the other people weren't checked by
the prophet suppose a teacher gives the
notes 100 students are copying how do I
know whether it's right or wrong if I'm
giving a lecture if some people notes
down chapter number verse number chapter
number verse number how fast can they
note down and if I don't verify they say
oh Dr. You said this reference where did
I say it?
Have I checked it? So what happened
later on? There were many variants
version of the Quran. Version means
people thought their own notes to be the
real Quran. And when Islam spread people
did not know which was the real Quran.
So at that time whatever the compiled
copy was there when Abu Bak may Allah be
pleased with him during these scribes it
was then in the hand of the wife of
prophet
may Allah be pleased with her and then
Usman ordered that copy may Allah be
pleased with him and had a replication
so that it could be sent to different
parts of the world and then he said
whatever copy you have whether right or
wrong you burn it because that hasn't
been verified. So people had their own
notes.
Suppose someone makes notes of my
lecture. There are people making here
notes. Maybe 80% is right. 90% 100% is
very difficult. Correct.
100% is very difficult. So 80% even if
it's 100% correct. If I give you now
this is the book of my lecture, you
know, you'll be getting a book now.
Quran and modern science authenticated
by me. Your notes you throw it away. Why
does he require the notes? I have given
you a book anyway you're not getting the
full lecture you're getting part of the
lecture Quran modern science now that
part I'll tell you brother throw that
notes away this is correct authenticated
by me Dr. and n my book the same way
whatever was authenticated by the
prophet the revelation Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala may Allah be pleased with him
he said all the other copies should be
burned that does not mean there was
variant Quran there was one Quran that
was revealed but people when they wrote
with their own notes there were
differences so that's the reason now one
of the copies is even today present in
copaki museum in Istanbul so this and if
you check it with today's musaf it is
exactly the same word what Word to word,
letter to letter. That's the way. Even
if you try to change it, you cannot
because today there are millions of
people who know the Quran by heart. And
here in our audience, mashallah, we have
many huas. Mashallah, who know the Quran
by heart, even if you burn the copy, you
get all the together, you get together
again the original Quran, word to word,
letter can be reproduced. Hope that
answers the question. But isn't it the
same with the master reciters at the
time of Muhammad and the Zed's text was
compiled only after the death of
Muhammad. That's totally wrong to say
that what we have to realize that Zabid
he was appointed as the chief of the
scribes.
There were many Sabas together. He was
appointed at the chief and this was
personally verified by prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. And later on
at the time of haz may Allah be pleased
with him. It was made into a book form
because at that time there was no paper
there were no pen. It was written on
parchment on bones on blades on
different material. Then it was later
transferred to one uniform material and
made into a book form. Nowhere does it
say that there were different versions.
So all these scribes even when it was
written down again when others man when
he ordered may Allah be peace be with
him those people who were alive in the
group of the scribes he called them and
among them again Zhabat he was appointed
as the leader hope that answers the
question
can we have the next question
uh brother Zakir Assalamu alaykum I'm
Namita a kindergarten teacher by
profession
First of all, let me congratulate you
for all your commendable work in
spreading the message of peace, love and
brotherhood.
I want to ask you brother Nyak if Quran
is the God's word if Islam is truly the
way of life then why are people taking
so long in realizing and accepting it
sister that's a very good question Quran
the word of God. Islam is a religion.
Why are people taking so long and
accepting it? Sister,
the straight path is not always easy to
follow. Your perception differs. The
perception of each individual differs.
For example,
a person who may not be following Islam.
Oh, if I accept Islam, he may be an
alcoholic. I'll have to stop having
alcohol. I may have to stop going out
with girls and dating. So then that will
prevent him. So what he thinks okay fine
Islam may be good but I don't want to
stop my alcohol. I don't want to stop
going out flirting with girls. I don't
want to stop having pork. So when you
learn there may be certain hitches that
may come. Maybe a person may not be
alcoholic. Maybe he may not be having
pork but he may think okay now I accept
Islam. That means for 40 years I was a
fool. Oh I better not accept Islam. Some
may think if I exam what will my friend
say what will my mother say what will my
father say so all these obstacles sister
only if you can overcome these obstacles
can you accept the truth so therefore
what you have to realize that the
message is clear the message is logical
it's absolutely clear but there are
other things which are there in the
baggage a person has to be so strong
that fine if this is the truth I'm try
to accept the truth even have to leave
my other non-Muslim friends and believe
me sister this is only a perception and
my non-Muslims who have accepted Islam
and yet they have got the old friends
and people tell me oh zakir don't speak
to non-Muslim you lose the friendship
I've got very good non-Muslim friends
also mash they respect me you have
appreciated me mah you're a non-Muslim
so my job is to present the truth and
one more thing Quran clearly mentions in
surah bakar chapter number two verse
number 256 like rafid there's no
compulsion in religion truth stands out
clear from error our job sisters to
present the truth whether a person
accepts it or not it depends upon him if
almighty god wanted everyone to accept
it's very easy it's mentioned in the
Quran in surah ununus chapter number 10
verse number 99 if he wanted he could
have made all the human beings believers
very easy
but where is the
Allah says in the Quran
in chapter number 67 verse number two
it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you is good in
deeds. So this life sister is a test for
the hereafter. Now when a person
realizes the truth everything you
realize the truth you don't follow. You
may follow 80% you may follow 50%. There
are very few people who follow 100%.
Even all the Muslims don't follow 100%.
Some Muslim may have bad habit yet
they are Muslim. So what we have
realized sister the major points of
oneness of God and believing in the last
and final messenger and believing in the
hereafter these two three points are the
most important sister and that the same
thing I'll tell you sister you ask me
the question I'll ask you the same
question then what is taking you so much
time to accept the sister
Dr.
I would just like to tell you something
that here with your blessings I accept
Islam and repeat the kalma
illister
[cheering]
may Allah may Allah bless you and may
Allah come to Jenna inshallah [applause]
we welcome you sister
and may Allah subhana wa ta'ala Blessed
and Jenna. Amen.
Uh may we have the next question from
the brother in the front.
Firstly sir congratul for arrang this
program. I'm advocate Shivaji Sapkar
from bid Maharashtra.
This program is peace for all. I get
opportunity to ask question
but my question is not related Quran.
Yes sir. Yes
sir. There are lacks of Marati speakers
I also Marati.
What is the role of IRF means Islamic
Research Foundation?
What
IRF doing for Marati or non-Muslims?
That was a very good question. Since we
living in the state of Maharashtra, he's
asking what are we doing as far as
Marati is concerned and what are we
doing for non-Muslims? As far as Marati
is concerned, I'll be very frank with
you.
We want to do
but we aren't doing much. There are some
of my books being translated into Marati
by others because I can understand
Marati but I can't speak Marati.
I mean I should be able to do it. We are
trying to make our children speak many
languages but I can understand marati
but I can't speak little bit I can but I
don't master of the language then maybe
then I would have given lectures in
marati also but we have some speakers in
IRF who give lectures in marati we are
brother Abdul Gapur kureshi whenever
there's a request to speak in marati we
send him so what we are doing we are
training people to speak and convey the
message of peace in different languages
languages the training program is in
English and many people know three four
languages so the training program is in
English sometimes udu and Hindi then he
goes if he's coming from South Africa
from Africa then he speaks in the
African language many people are coming
from other parts of the world from
Malaysia they have come they have come
from USA they have come from Singapore
from Saudi Arabia from Philippine Tagalu
I don't know Tal what I do I convey the
message in English I tell the people to
convey in Tagalu. I'm requesting you
brother, convey my message, what you
have learned here, heard here to those
people on Amarati.
Yes sir.
You'll be doing a favor to me.
Yes. Yes sir.
Inshallah. That's the first question.
Come to the second question. What are we
doing for non-Muslims?
Again, we aren't doing much. Whatever
limited we can do, there's so much to be
done. Though organization is big,
mashallah,
we have got more than 2,000 volunteers.
Yet I'm saying we are doing nothing. We
are a very small organization,
very small. We have organized this
conference.
We are giving first chance to
non-Muslims because you are a VIP guest,
a special guest.
You today are more closer to me than the
other Muslims. Why? Because I have to
convey. Allah will ask me on the day of
judgment, have I conveyed the message or
not? So I'm trying my level best to
convey personally on this level.
Furthermore, this conference a 10day
conference we have invited non-Muslims
and we mentioned in the postal all faith
welcome people of all religion welcome
but in question answer session we give
them first preference we give them
priority so that the doubts can be
cleared even the Muslims have got doubts
the Muslims they get angry with me what
about us afterward no problem Okay.
Okay.
So what we have besides giving the
message here maybe there are tens of
thousands of people here now mashallah
tens of thousands of people but there
are more than 60 million people watching
live but yet we are doing nothing per se
Islam foundation what we should do we
are doing very little but we are trying
our level best and we pray to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala that may accept our
humble effort that we are doing in
trying to spread his message to the
world hope that answers the Yes. Wish
you all the best for your organization
sir.
Uh yes brother. The next question.
My name is Sahil. I'm a graphic
designer. I'm a poet. May peace be on
you Dr. Zakir. I always wanted to say
this. I've got a chance by God's grace
today. I love you Dr. Zakir. I love you
very very much.
And I thank you.
May peace be on you too brother. And I
thank you.
I do love you. I do love you brother.
Thank you. And I thank you for the ample
amount of knowledge I've got going
through your lectures from my friends,
from my sister Nagma. And there's a
slight bit of confusion
uh between the word of God and the
people who believe the concept of
judgment day. Like there's a small
question. We believe like like the
Muslims believe that on the judgment day
the dead will be put life in them.
And some of the Muslims believe that it
will be on the first night in the grave
that the dead will be put life and
there'll be a and questions and answers
in in the grave. So I just wanted to
clarify this. That's it. The brother
asked the question that the difference
opinion will life be put on the day of
judgment on the day of judgment
resurrected or will it be in the coverar
brother if you read the hadith that is
mentioned of the
Allah says in the Quran in Imran chapter
number three verse 185 that
every soul shall have a taste of death
but the final recompense will be on the
day of judgment. This life is just mere
chatters of play and deception. But the
final habitat, final judgment is on the
day of judgment.
What we have to do? We may get part of
the punishment in this world, part of
the reward in this world, part of the
reward in the kabar, part of the aab in
the kabar, but the final ultimate
judgment is on the day of judgment. The
final total of good and bad will be
recorded on the day of judgment. And
then based on your deeds, you will
either go to heaven or hell. Some of
this will be given in this world, some
in the grave, but the final accounting
will be on day of judgment. Hope that
answers the question.
Thank you.
Yes, sister.
Hi, I'm an American student studying
culture and theology and I have a
question. You said Jesus never claims
his divinity and that Jesus was only
here for Jews, but the Bible says, "Tell
us if you are the Christ, the son of
God." And Jesus replied, "Yes, it is as
you say." And then in Matthew 28:18-20,
Jesus says to his disciples,
"All authority in heaven and on earth
has been given to me. Therefore, go and
make disciples
of all nations, baptizing them in the
name of the Father and of the Son and of
the Holy Spirit, and teaching them to
obey everything I have commanded you.
And surely I am with you always to the
very end of the age.
Sister has quoted two verses from the
Bible. The first one from you who said
that Jesus claimed that you're son of
God. Did you say that sister?
Yes sir.
Son of God. And second she said that
Jesus said go to all the nations. What
she's quoting is the ending last portion
of the gospel of Matthew. If you go
earlier sister mentioned the gospel of
Matthew chapter number 15 verse number
24. He says to his apostles that I have
been sent not but to the lost sheep of
the house of Israel. What you quote it
according to the scholars of the Bible
what they say that is an interpolation.
But whether it is or not I don't want to
argue. But then there's a contradiction
in the Bible. The Bible clearly mentions
in the gospel of Matthew
chapter number 10 verse number 5 and 6.
Jesus Christ peace be upon him says to
his apostles go ye not into the way of
the Gentiles. going not in the way of
the non-Jews, the Hindus, the Muslims,
but rather go to the lordship of the
house of Israel. As far as the first
question is concerned that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said that I am the son
of God. Sister, do you know in the Bible
God has got sons by the tongues. Adam
was the son of God. Ephraim a son of
God. Israel was son of God. All those
who are led by the spirit of God, they
are sons of God. So if you're a
righteous person, you're a son of God.
If I'm a righteous person, I'm a son of
God. That is the language of the Bible.
As far as calling son of God to a
righteous person, I do agree that since
prophet Jesus was a messenger of God, he
should be called the son of God. But
what do the Christian missionaries say?
No, no, no, no. He is not a normal son.
He is the begotten son. And they quote
the Bible, Gospel of John, chapter
number three, verse number 16. For God
so loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son whosoever believe in him
shall not perish but have everlasting
life. So what we have to realize that
this verse of the Bible begotten son
according to the 32 scholars of the
highest eminence of 50 corporate
denominations if you read the RSV
revised time version they say this word
begotten is interpolation is a
concoction is a fabrication and they're
thrown out the Bible. So Jesus is not
the begotten son because begotten means
it belongs to an action of animals of
lower level.
So he's verily the son of god. Son
meaning a righteous person. We have no
objection but he's not the begotten son.
He begets not know his begotten. I hope
that answers the question.
Alhamdulillah.
We thank Allah subhana wa tala for
making this program possible. We know
you have many questions but there are
time limitations to the program. We
thank Allah subhananaa tala not only for
making this program possible but for
creating this opportunity for a better
understanding on the topic for the
millions of people too other than those
present here watching us on television
who may inshallah share some of the
learnings from this talk and question
and answer sessions to others less aware
for them to gain better understanding
and haya too.
We thank all who have contributed and
made this program practically possible
for all present here today and for its
telecast and those who have come to
attend this program.